I adore you you're you're such a
terrific comedic actress who can also do
drama you're so good at what you do but
also uh and we won't get into specifics
but you are so smart about people and
you and I have had conversations where
different people will come up in the
industry whatever and you are so
incisive not mean just so incisive about
human beings what makes them tick what
you've noticed and I always walk away
and think like this is an incredible
person
that's so nice no it's true I I mean
this a hundred I believe you and that's
like I don't think anybody's ever said
that to me and I think it's the greatest
compliment I've ever received and I'm
not even being
like flippant about it that's a great
thing to have somebody but it's true I'm
thinking specifically of different times
people have come up and you'll you'll
say something and it's just I feel like
you have a bit of a superpower not a bit
of a it is a superpower to be able to
just see people for who they are in this
business that's tricky it's really
tricky and thanks part of this journey
of this podcast started with me just
wanting to be uh very honest if I could
talking to people who anyone else would
envy and saying yes it is great I am not
complaining but also it is very
complicated and there's a lot of strange
people in this business and there's a
lot of our uh buttons get pushed and I
feel like that is something that you are
aware of
and you've handled it really well I do
feel like I've been sort of positioned
in a just geographically positioned well
meaning I'm from La I have these friends
that I grew up with it's probably like
10 to 15 of us who have been friends
since we were little kids like five
years old and none of them do this and I
don't have to get on a plane to go see
this group of friends they're here in
the city that I live in most of the time
and so I think that's been helpful like
say don't care
and they genuinely don't care but like
in a loving way whereas some people say
that they don't care like okay so going
back to what you're saying because of
Thanksgiving right just happened and
I was talking to Tom and it's like it's
almost like if you do this for a living
what we do it's like a family disease
like
the way that tell me if you agree with
this okay so I'm with my family who are
amazing and wonderful but a lot of
family friends different people kind of
come in and you get a lot of like I
don't know if it comes from like I'm
gonna prove to you that I'm not
impressed that you're an actress I don't
care that you're an actress so I'm going
to say mean [ __ ] to you yeah all the
time yeah and you kind of just take it
and it's fine but like it's always
family friends are like some distant ant
that's like I saw that show it wasn't
for me
so much I liked the other thing you did
you're like cool I just spent eight
months of my life I don't go to like
your accountancy office and say like you
know what you're doing just fine I don't
and you sort of have to take these blows
like all the time and they're not a big
deal but right also nobody wants to hear
you complain about it's a tricky
Balancing Act we were talking on the
podcast once to David Sedaris and he was
talking about this exact same phenomenon
and I said to him
I get this sense that there are people
that need to tax you meaning they apply
a bit of a tax to you because they think
in some way you need to pay them a
little bit for your whatever success or
perceived better life you know I don't
know and it's very complicated because
it's so funny because they people
wouldn't do that in another situation
and I've actually said to people
sometimes it rarely happens but the time
when people are just being
downright rude I'll say to them I do not
expect you to treat me better than other
people I want to be but I wanted to be
treated as well as you treat other
people totally and so the idea that no
but
I'm sure other people kiss your ass so
I'm gonna I'm gonna cross a crowded room
and tell you by the way I never quite
got it you're like wow okay totally
that's impressive and it's I mean you
have it on a much different scale than I
do and I see also that it would be
really annoying for let's say your
family to have you know your sibling
have somebody's always trying to talk to
your sibling about you yeah that would
suck like I wouldn't handle that well at
all but I also don't personally feel
successful or famous or any of those
things ever like I don't think that's
the reality of my situation and so when
people occasionally like to
kind of Stick it to me I'm like but I
was just I was just sitting here okay
it is true you do just sit around a lot
a lot
every time I've bumped into Lizzy anyway
she's just sitting I enjoying a rock or
sitting on a bench yeah and I'm like
what are you doing it's just just
sitting here when you find a nice rock
the impasse of that opportunity be yes
and then like the Dirty Little Secret is
like nobody wants to hear you complain
and you know you shouldn't actually
complain to many people about this it's
not a universal experience but it is a
weird thing where it becomes and I see
it with a lot of friends or any like
little bits of success I've had it's it
just you're like up the level of
isolation and because nobody wants to
hear you let's say you let's make it
about you Kelly okay nobody wants to
hear you complain because you are very
successful and you have a lot of money
and whatever oh I lost a lot of it oh
you used to have a lot of money I I
bought up an entire collection of put
all my money into Victorian pornography
yeah which is not racy at all it's a lot
of clothes yeah
I'm your own customer yeah
and after you had bought like eight
thousand dollars worth yeah you were
cleaned out yeah but no I uh
it's true and I I go through this all
the time which is I'm very clear with a
lot of people I chose my life I've you
know had some ups and downs but I'm the
dictionary definition of very lucky in
every way in my personal life my my my
work I have absolutely nothing to
complain about and I would like that on
my Tombstone which would be ironic
because I'd be dead which is a
legitimate thing to complain about it is
how about up until this point I had
nothing to complain about it yeah
1963 2025.
oh no no that gives me a little time I
know but I have to fix up my resume
I gotta start looking for other work
come on I know you guys are do you want
to start a podcast I would love to okay
I really like it here for free yeah we
can just keep the same space yeah okay
let's move from there to there trust me
you would everyone would be very happy
with that